[Music]
oh hi everyone out there in the virtual
world it is time for dear drew
i am so grateful that you take the time
to put pen to paper
and stamps to envelopes and send your
wonderful snail mail
our zip code that we're celebrating
today is
21206 baltimore maryland
that's right hello baltimore
known by many nicknames through the
years including charm city the city that
reads the monumental city and the city
that believes those are great nicknames
i've had a few nicknames of my own never
that nice no all right well you try the
hometown of baseball legend babe ruth
baltimore maryland we would love to hear
from you send us some mail and now let's
get to our letter
um
i get so excited by stamps i might
become a stamp collector hashtag nerd
alert
dear true
my favorite segment of yours is drew's
news thanks
you've inspired me to become a news and
pop culture junkie i love you and ross
together what a team yes
love drew's news so much that i've
written a poem just for you
news it's true's news you'll never get
the blues it's drew's news
the intro that melts the room it's
drew's news you'll walk away anew
it's drew's news
toy i have no idea if i enhanced your
poem or took it down a notch but i do
appreciate it
toy from baltimore maryland
not only for putting pen to paper and
stamp to envelope by the way i do love
your stamps they are really doing
something for me
but you wrote a poem thank you
everything about this is absolute poetry
to me
thank you toy i am sending you a
postcard in return
truly yours
true
[Music]